I will define for you a normal distribution with a specific mean
that's often called µ, Greek letter µ,
and a variance that's often called σ².
We already know that variance is a quadratic expression.
In normal land we often use µ and σ². Let's do this.
The very first element is that for any outcome x we write the quadratic difference
between this outcome x and µ.
This is indeed a function in x. So, look at this.
Here are four possible hypotheses of what this function might look like.
Each case is µ is on the right side some where.
The horizontal axis is x, and we're graphing f(x).
The first I'll give you is a triangular function.
The second is a quadratic function.
The third one is a negative quadratic function.
And the fourth one is a quadratic function that doesn't quite touch µ.
So, which one in your opinion best describes this formula over here?